Elijah Wood enters what's going on
you know just raining in New York just
raining raining yeah boss and that's
Sarah Matt Serra's very excited that
you're here he's freaked out a minute
ago when we told them you were coming
yeah I don't wanna I don't want to bring
up the whole Lord of the Rings things
get a little much because I know you're
like just what you know like it would be
shitty if I were to start to be
disingenuous about that yeah I they were
incredible experiences in my life and I
loved those movies so those films are
gonna live on 400% and nothing so
powerful at you but the follow-up movies
The Hobbit yeah what kind of shitty no
those first three oh my god nerdgasm
yeah what the follow-ups didn't do it
for you don't get me wrong some awesome
eye candy with the [ __ ] the way they
were doing everything but uh you didn't
like him no I thought the dragon was
pretty income like Godfather 3 I loved
what they did by weaving in the
appendices into the Hobbit cuz like all
our fantasy I know it is peeled they
deal with with what is it happening
chronologically at the same time that
Bilbo's on the journeys yeah all that
stuff with Gandalf going to deal with
the necromancer and all that isn't in
The Hobbit
so that stuff which is essentially all
of this sort of prelude to what
ultimately becomes sour on lorries I
found that stuff really fascinating
stuff was cool like you like that like
that backstory part of it yeah it's just
some stuff with the the major difference
of those films is that they they only
shot I think a month or two of exteriors
on Lord of the Rings we were shooting on
location all the time New Zealand right
how is it didn't shoot a lot of location
stuff on The Hobbit
how hard is it you break your in the
character you break the character you
know in life then you got to go back to
the character is it hard to go back and
forth through that transition like when
you're in character and making the movie
how long like when you walk off the set
are you completely back - yeah okay
normally I guess actors that stay in
character all the time some people who
have an accent will keep their accent
going but you're not the first actor to
do a sequel either so that that would be
something that actors are able to do or
that happen to go back and play that
character because obviously the
character does not exist in the context
of the Hopf but he only exists within
the Lord of the Rings so it was a
surprise but yeah it it was we what was
weird about it was how normal it felt
that's what was strange not that it was
suddenly me playing the character again
it was weird how it felt like no time
have passed like it felt like time
travel in a buried surreal amazing way
do you really wish deep down inside you
did Harry Potter instead Potter - and
and you know those films are excellent
but um they were shot over a very very
long period of time you know we shot
Lord of the Rings really over the course
of 16 months and the better part of four
years but that was it Harry Potter what
is that in the new it's eight films and
then they've got the whole backstory
thing going on now with Eddie Redmayne
and it was lovely to have done it it
existed in that period of time and to
have moved on I don't know about Matt
where are you at with Harry Potter the
younger kids I think grew up on that
yeah
yeah generation I like the Lord of the
Rings when it was a cartoon movie yeah I
mean that did you ever see the cartoon
movie the Lord it's great yeah it's
great so great Walt the rotoscoping they
did what was Macklin max landis like did
you work with him yeah on this yeah show
because he's not the director but he
created an executive produced and
exactly is like and Kosho ran it yeah he
was on set a lot he's wonderful
I mean he's an incredible writer have
you guys ever met him I haven't met him
but I know him no personality tornado oh
yeah he's a young guy and he is I mean
he's a tornado and he figured out a way
he kind of his projects are his projects
completely you know what I mean like he
writes for himself - yeah the Edit in
direct into all that stuff okay one film
but as a writer yeah he's done a thing
that's very unprecedented where he's
tried to to get things sold that he has
some degree of control over yeah which
is really not common how many guys sell
your script and it goes and whatever
happens happens and you have no control
how many guys have final editor whatever
it was we'll do as Kubrick at one point
maybe Coppola he's like vert obscure
says he almost nobody gets that by the
way yeah yeah the Blues Brothers
I don't know Animal House yes or my
father
so you guys are doing it we were just
talking about how bizarre the show
watching the show last night yeah and
what a busy day how many episodes of
I've just seen the first one okay and
it's a super trippy thing but I was
wondering for you like to go on from
Wilfred which was a pretty mod mod show
yeah - this like is it just something
where it's like if I'm gonna do TV it's
got to be
something we had way left-of-center not
entirely but I I think I'm I'm just I'm
drawn to things that feel different
yeah I feel exciting and feel as if they
exist within their own universe or are
trying to push things in different
directions that were not used to that's
just an exciting thing creatively to be
a part of what was the movie you did
that was well you became promote it was
a bizarre movie it was good though
you're obsessed with mannequins Oh
maniac oh yeah that was that was an
enjoyment in it so that was good it was
weird sounds creepy totally different
yeah yeah it was a remake of a night
early in 1980s horror film yeah well I
remade it where the entire thing was
primarily shot from the POV of the kill
that's right well you don't have to I
guess you don't really have to work at
this point in your life you gets not
entirely true really yeah I have to keep
working well I mean financially I would
imagine you're pretty well not the money
though yeah cuz I would do something
else I suppose if I didn't Yeah right
but that but I mean you get to you get
to do things that are odd I try to I
kind of only I would rather not work
than work on things that I don't care
about right I'd rather do something else
because there's other ways to make money
and I think I don't know if you're in a
creative field you should be doing it
because you love it and and go for the
things that you're passionate about
otherwise it's it can be a bit of a slog
but when it comes to arranging the work
is hard I'm anxious to see I haven't
seen it yet but I've seen the trailers
for the greasy
other greasy story sees triangle that
you guys would love that
that's your company the a reduced it huh
what about the trailers have amazing
such a good trailer like every character
in the thing it looks from the trailer
yeah my assessment is there's there's a
serial killer that's on the loose that
strangles people and lose them all like
greasy like Crisco and yeah all of his
naked body in grease kills people yes
but at the same time there's this like
it's like so about a father and a son
but this really weird like ugly looking
son who's got this equally odd-looking
father and he gets a girlfriend but then
the father starts [ __ ] the girl from
the trailers that sort of
and the filmmaker Jim Hosking is a
British director he's done a lot of
shorts and really great commercials
he really has a certain aesthetic that's
very much his own yeah kind of creates
his own worlds and populates them with
kind of a lot of the times non actors or
certainly actors we're not familiar with
so it really is delving into it's kind
of like the early John Waters in the
sense that yes is very define ibly John
Waters yeah Jim is very similar in that
sense and this movie is sort of the
first is first feature that kind of is a
long a long-form story do you like super
weird the very funny get content to
people now like you can find an audience
for things you don't mean because of
digital releases and stuff like that
like this movie would get lost you know
it'd become one of those cult things
that you found on film and like oh
what's this what but now it's they can
get that trailer out and iTunes etcetera
Twitter yeah with this film so it was
released theatrically but it the same
day it was released in theaters you
could get it on iTunes yeah which is
great for a movie like this cuz there
was so much buzz buzz leading up to it
we premiered at Sundance that there's
certainly enthusiasm for this weird
[ __ ] movie that people can see it
immediately if they want or if they live
in New York or LA and any of the places
that it's playing in the theater you can
go see it too you go back to max landis
because I realize that we kind of got
off track trying to figure out what
movies his dad did places Matt was
correct way to go to points thank you
how is he
in terms of because he likes to have his
hands on so much is he a guy that's
gonna tell you and along with the
director obviously exactly the way this
story is being told or is there
flexibility to kind of move with him
it's kind of both curly it is both yeah
because he he can have very fixed ideas
and he said about what he wants but then
if you show him something he's delighted
like he loves you throwing new ideas at
him yeah so it's both and how quick does
it take for you to trust a guy like that
you know any until I trust this person's
vision I I trusted him instantly because
of the script
yeah like a script was so tight and so
well formed and so brilliantly
intricately plotted that it was like
this guy knows what he's doing so he pre
artists the I always say Trust has to be
earned that's just kind of my motto
sometimes you just get paid to trust me
take the offer without reading the
script there's so much to offer me just
talking about like the integrity and
doing projects ey ya and then boss on
the other side who if it's an offer you
should that's me I'm Shane I'm a comic
I'm not an actor someone says hey you
want to do this is it true that you
don't you never know from reading a
script what will be a hit or a miss or
is it just your instincts or is it
somebody in your ear your agent or
something saying this will be good for
you or is it you gut make sure it's
always a gut response to material but
yeah you never know how something is
gonna turn out the amount of times that
I I don't know if you've had this the
amount of times where it's like this is
gonna be really good for you and it's
gonna be huge and it just dies and it's
not for one of people trying it's not
for it not being good it just for some
reason it doesn't hit it doesn't come
together and then other things where you
have no idea and you think I just love
this it's no one's gonna see it I love
I'm gonna do it and it just blows up
I've had the first part happen but is
there anything that stands out that you
didn't take and you say you know what I
might do this I may not you don't do it
and then it ends up being good you're
like [ __ ] oh no no I mean there's
certainly things that I I'm sure you
have the same things that we would go up
for that we don't I don't get you then
see was huge and amazing and yeah all
the time I mean I for Rushmore oh wow
and I remember that audition so clearly
because I had seen Bottlerocket and I
was a huge fan of bottle rockets this is
before like he became the filmmaker that
we now know and I was just so excited to
meet the film maker of bottle rocket
right and I didn't get the film but it
didn't it was like one of those things
that it's become it's one of my favorite
movies of all time so I don't know man I
always feel like I genuinely believe
those things work out the way they're
supposed to yeah yeah and they're
definitely been things that I've gone up
for I've met
and things that I've chosen not to do
but I always feel like they happen you
know they everything in your life leads
to the next thing whether good or bad
this is this is very Dec generally
everything's can well I sure would is a
holistic actor yeah you doing that you
guys are doing an AMA later today right
yeah we are now I don't know o'clock
East East Coast time I don't know who's
in charge of this thing but I want you
to tell them to learn from Ken bones
mistakes did you hear about what
happened to him I know I did account
yeah new username for an AMA you need a
new user actually have it read it
username at all me neither
okay so we're not gonna read it I'm not
like trolling anything you know who can
bone was saying so chem bone is the guy
yeah bit of a phenomenon yeah yeah he
got a good five days yeah it happened
when he came up and asked the first that
question I was like it's Kaelin time and
so so this is this is Ken bone he it was
the second the right question yeah he
was one of the the gentleman that came
up and asked a question but I mean look
at this beautiful man
so he's crazy for awesome but he came
into a bit of controversy Radiohead was
his favorite band by the way which I
thought was pretty awesome was that
buried in there under the bad stuff
maybe why we did an AMA right but he
used his reddit name that he's had for
years oh and so they just clicked his
name and started going through all his
old posts and as it turns out he thinks
trayvon martin was justifiably murdered
legal term legal terms he's into
pregnant porn
he loves a pregnant woman's own body
okay one can have been finding pregnant
women sexy is kind of alright that's
probably the healthiest one like well I
like the idea I mean he also he also
posted a thing that said that he liked
Jennifer Lawrence's butthole baby great
you don't want
yeah unseemly I don't know if it's like
total character assassination no you I
like Jared jennifer lawrence's asked
fall I'd love that to be on my rip why
not for you it'd be like that was also
like a photo that was not it was when
all those photos were stolen is the
Fanning and that's not right right right
right that's not good he was just a guy
who asked the question at the
presidential debate and the internet
just went crazy for him because he's a
big fat guy in a red sweater with a
mustache yeah and said they just went
nuts for him
yeah well perfectly round skull I think
people are gonna go nuts for Dirk
gently's holistic you can see the show
Saturday at 9:00 p.m. on BBC America Sam
Barnett Elijah Wood thank you guys for
being here it's a really fun show and
it's a it's very bizarre and violent and
people get shot in the head and it's fun
it gets weird it's really weird to get
weird yeah we'll support the show thank
you guys for being here thanks guys